dernier regard sur l'ancienne qui
trônait à l'intérieur la vente du
bâtiment mais surtout la pandémie aura
sonné le glas de la mythique boîte à
chansons immense le père de marie lou a
ouvert lé de pierrot en 74 à l'époque où
les centaines de boîtes à chanson
faisait le bonheur des chansonniers de
leur public à la grandeur du québec un
endroit où le québécois vient lui même
et participer dans sa culture
je dirais qu'au début dans les années
soixante quatorze beaucoup le veulent
[Musique]
les artistes devaient présenter 70% de
leur répertoire en français une
obligation encore en place aujourd'hui
en plein mois de juillet on pouvait
jouer chez eux aux jo de là et on
sentait comme système nouvelle un test
en place aussi à ce que nous on pouvait
jouer nos compos obligeant sont ouverts
à ce ce que les gens recherchent et
avoir du plaisir danser chanter taper
des mains faire le petit train sont le
retrouver en 74 pour le retrouver en
2020 c'était la même chose des soirées
inoubliables pour la clientèle qui
attendaient parfois dans de longues
files pour rentrer quand tu rentres de
pierrot tu connais l'ambiance une soirée
bien accro à l'ambiance
frédéric est tombé en amour mais pas
seulement avec l'endroit
notre premier baiser c'est à dire ici
haut du perron jeu ça des escaliers le
prg à la salle de bains mais moi je
voyais nulle part que juste elle pendant
25 ans chadi a été responsable de la
sécurité
un honneur pour lui on aurait pu écrire
service à la clientèle on aurait pu
écrire bureau d'information la rapide
n'importe quoi et puis ça faisait le
travail parce que justement la vente
clientèle qui avait tellement
sympathique
voilà qu'une fenêtre sur la culture
québécoise se ferme
mais le deux pierrots n'a pas dit son
dernier mot n'est pas la fin de pierrot
c'est certain il va avoir à y voir
d'autres choses ici marie josée paquet
comme radio canada montréal